[Música]
antigamente no beija sapo todo mundo
beijava na cara de todo mundo agora é
tudo escondido no tinga sem vergonhice
boa noite
é a primeira vez que eu faço uma
palestra como essa eu quero tentar
passar um pouco da minha história é bom
aos 21 anos de idade em belo horizonte
eu resolvi jogar tudo pro alto não
tivesse muita coisa devido algumas
questões pessoais familiares
eu tinha um carro fruto da minha
primeira meta conquistado com grande
esforço a minha segunda meta era ter uma
carreira para conseguir isso
vendi o carro e com dinheiro foi para
são paulo trabalhar como modelo que era
a oportunidade que eu tinha na minha
época naquela época
aos 21 anos de idade fica fácil jogar
tudo pro alto e começar do zero
e assim foi instalei naquela cidade
imensa sozinha e comecei a trabalhar na
primeira semana conseguiu um trabalho de
modelo o seu primeiro mês de aluguel
estava garantido na semana seguinte eu
consegui um outro bem notável que me
deixou em evidência
era um comercial para uma marca de
refrigerantes que me garantiu além de
mais um mês de aluguel um convite para
fazer uma novela na tv globo
eu sou muito grata pelo jogo da vida
daí ele eram 13 anos trabalhando na
televisão passei pelas principais
emissoras do país vive momentos doces
inesquecíveis e outros nem tanto
durante todos esses anos os meus pés
sempre estiveram no chão nos altos e
baixo
eu estava lá com os meus pés de tênis
durante todo esse turbilhão de coisas
completamente sozinha eu conhecia aquele
que seria o meu principal aliado
o sport entrei numa assessoria de
triathlon na qual faço parte até hoje e
tenho o maior carinho e me inscrevi na
minha primeira maratona foi um dos
grandes acertos na minha vida porque o
esporte se tornou a minha maior
companhia e o responsável por manter os
meus pés no chão a minha calma com
certeza de que nada é tão bom que não
podia acabar e nem tão ruim que duraria
para sempre em do vih na produzida no
seu cérebro é um analgésico natural
incrível é amor foi o seu corpo para
quem tinha dores que talvez anos e anos
de terapia não resolvessem o sporting
entrava como a minha salvação
a atividade física é muito poderosa
se você se dedicar diariamente a ela e
números serão os benefícios melhora do
sono do humor é só qualidade de vida
enfim a lista é longa
eu não tô falando sobre estética sobre
ter uma barriga sarada
estou falando sobre autoconhecimento e
conseqüentemente você ser uma pessoa
melhor para enfrentar as adversidades da
vida
quando estou correndo nadando ou
pedalando o som do mundo se silencia
mills
no resumo bastante eu deixo os rótulos
que vieram de fora onde estão
eu não permito que eles entrem no meu
coração
ali eu me conecto com mim mesma eu rezo
eu tenho os meus limites e eu tenho
certeza de que eu resolvo os meus
problemas naquele mesmo lugar
a maratona de nova york
aquela primeira que eu mencionei aqui no
começo da nossa conversa teve um sabor
muito especial
meu avô praticamente um segundo pai
pessoa que sempre me acolheu com muito
amor e carinho e teve paralisia infantil
doença que limitou e muito seus
movimentos
ele não podia correr uma maratona mas eu
sim eu poderia através do meu treino de
corpo e mente quando você está numa
corrida de 42 quilômetros
lembra o frio à fome à fadiga tudo joga
contra
é nesse momento que você aprende a ser
resiliente
você sabe que você teve todo um
treinamento de corpo e mente para fazer
aquilo
tem uma frase que eu amo que diz o
desafio de querer não é querer o desafio
de correr não é realizar coisas que
ninguém já vaz fez antes mas sim de
continuar a fazer coisas que qualquer um
pode fazer mas que a maioria jamais fará
isso significa muito para mim imagina
que a história da maratona reza a lenda
que um herói correu 42 quilômetros de
maratona a atenas para noticiar a
vitória da grécia
ele morreu mas foi até o fim
a minha primeira chegada teve um sabor
muito inspirador que você com foco com
treinamento de corpo e mente
você pode fazer o que você quiser essa
conversa que a gente está tendo aqui não
é somente sobre corrida ou qualquer
outro esporte é soube traçar uma meta
chegar lá
importa com duro caminho seja coloca o
seu objetivo e vai lá
você quer abrir um negócio que é cuidar
da sua saúde quer se tornar uma pessoa
melhor sair
é isso hoje é meu marido
a gente treina juntos mas o que a gente
ama passa bastante tempo juntos
eu tenho certeza que eu não vou mais
ficar sozinha e outro dia eu levei a
minha filha de seis anos para esquiar
ela me perguntou mamãe quando você tinha
6 anos vocês que ava de maneira alguma
por muitas vezes me faltou mínimo
esquiável nem sabia o que era isso
então eu pedi a ela que aproveitasse
aquela viagem à herança do esporte que
eu estou deixando pra ela com todos os
ensinamentos ela viveu uma vida saudável
e alegre
o sport nunca me abandonou sempre foi
meu maior aliado e hoje eu divido com a
mesma mídia treinar lavar roupa da minha
casa sou eu que lavar minha roupa
quase morri quando alguém lavo fazer uma
faculdade de direito
usei esse vestido na minha formatura no
momento que eu trabalhava como
celebridades da tv não tinha tempo para
nada era uma loucura eu fui lá eu fui
até o fim
tudo isso para dizer que às vezes a
alegria da vida está nas simples coisas
o que importa
passa o que interessa
fica nessa noite eu quero te convidar a
usar o esporte como uma ferramenta
importante na sua jornada
não importa a fase de vida que você
esteja toma coragem e faça o que te faz
bem
permita se experimentar coisas novas
abra seu negócio declare seu amor alguém
permita o seu corpo sentir a enxurrada
de dopamina endorfina e serotonina que
pode invadir o seu corpo e transformar
sua vida
levanta e vai com muita fé porque vale a
pena último obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]